The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: As the question said,
where are we as far as
the text goes.
We're just going to
start Chapter 2
today, Poisson processes.
I want to spend about five
minutes reviewing a little bit
about convergence, the things
we said last time,
and then move on.
There's a big break in the
course, at this point between
Chapter 1 and Chapter 2 in the
sense that Chapter 1 is very
abstract, a little
theoretical.
It's dealing with probability
theory in general and the most
general theorems in probability
stated in very
simple and elementary form.
But still, we're essentially
not dealing with
applications at all.
We're dealing with very, very
abstract things in Chapter 1.
Chapter 2 is just the reverse.
A Poisson process is the
most concrete thing
you can think of.
People use that as a model
for almost everything.
Whether it's a reasonable
model or
not is another question.
But people use it as
a model constantly.
And everything about
it is simple.
For a Poisson process, you can
almost characterize it as
saying everything you could
think of about a Poisson
process is either true or
it's obviously false.
And when you get to
that point, you
understand Poisson processes.
And you can go on to other
things and never have to
really think about them
very hard again.
Because at that point, you
really understand them.
OK.
So let's go on and review
things a little bit.
What's convergence and how does
it affect sequences of
IID random variables?
Convergence is more
general than
just IID random variables.
But it applies to any sequence
of random variables.
And the definition is that a
sequence of random variables
converges in distribution to
another random variable z, if
the limit, as n goes to
infinity, of the distribution
function of zn converges to the
distribution function of z.
For this definition to make
sense, it doesn't matter what
z is. z can be outside of
the sample space even.
The only thing we're interested
in is this
particular distribution
function.
So what we're really saying is
a sequence of distributions
converges to another
distribution function if in
fact this limit occurs at every
point where f of z is
continuous.
In other words, if f of z is
discontinuous someplace, we
had an example of that where
we're looking at the law of
large numbers and the
distribution function.
Looked at in the right way
was a step function.
It wasn't continuous
at the step.
And therefore, you can't expect
anything to be said
about that.
So the typical example of
convergence in distribution is
the central limit theorem which
says, if x1, x2 are IID,
they have a variance
sigma squared.
And if s sub n the sum of these
random variables is a
sum of x1 to xn, then zn
is the normalized sum.
In other words, you
take this sum.
You subtract off
the mean of it.
And I think in the reproduction
of these slides
that you have, I think that
n, right there was--
here we go.
That's the other y.
I think that n was left off.
If that n wasn't left off,
another n was left off.
It's obviously needed there.
This is a normalized random
variable because the variance
of sn and of sn minus nx bar is
just sigma squared times n.
Because they're any of these
random variables.
So we're dividing by the
standard deviation.
So this is a random variable
for each n which has a
standard deviation
1 and mean 0.
So it's normalized.
And it converges in distribution
to a Gaussian
random variable of mean 0 and
standard deviation 1.
This notation here is
sort of standard.
And we'll use it at
various times.
It means a Gaussian distribution
with mean 0 and
variance 1.
So for an example of that, if
x1, x2, so forth, are IID with
mean expected value of x and the
sum here, then sn over n
converges in distribution to
the deterministic random
variable x bar.
That's a nice example of this.
So we have two examples of
convergence and distribution.
And that's what that says.
So next, a sequence of random
variables converges in
probability.
When we start talking about
convergence in probability,
there's another idea which we
are going to bring in, mostly
in Chapter 4 when we get
to it, which is called
convergence with
probability 1.
Don't confuse those two
things because they're
very different ideas.
Because people confuse them,
many people call convergence
with probability 1 almost sure
convergence or almost
everywhere convergence.
I don't like that notation.
So I'll stay with the notation
with probability 1.
But it means something very
different than converging in
probability.
So the definition is that a
set of random variables
converges in probability to some
other random variable if
this limit holds true.
And you remember that diagram
we showed you last time.
Let me just quickly redraw it.
Have this set of distribution
functions.
Here's the mean here,
x bar, limits,
plus and minus epsilon.
And this sequence of random
variables has to come in down
here and go out up there.
This distance here and the
distance there gets very small
and goes to 0 as n
gets very large.
And that's the meaning
of what this says.
So if you don't remember that
diagram, go look at it in the
lecture notes last time or in
the text where it's explained
in a lot more detail.
So the typical example of that
is the weak law of large
numbers of x1, blah, blah,
blah, are IID with mean,
expected value of x.
Remember now that we say that
a random variable has a mean
if the expected value of the
absolute value of x is finite.
It's not enough to have things
which have a distribution
function which is badly behaved
for very big x, and
badly behaved for very small
x, and the two of them
cancelled out.
That doesn't work.
That doesn't mean
you have a mean.
You need the expected value
as the absolute
value of x to be finite.
Now, the weak law of large
numbers says that the random
variables sn over n, in other
words, the sample average, in
fact converges to the
deterministic
random variable x bar.
And that convergence is
convergence in probability.
Which means it's this kind
of convergence here.
Which means that it's going
to a distribution
which is a step function.
There's a very big difference
between a distribution which
is a step function and a
distribution which is
something like a Gaussian
random variable.
And what the big difference is
is that the random variables
that are converging to each
other, if a bunch of random
variables are all converging to
a constant, then they all
have to be very close
to each other.
And that's the property you're
really interested in in
convergence in probability.
So convergence in mean square,
finally, last definition which
is easy to deal with.
If a sequence of random
variables converges in the
mean square to another random
variable, if this limit of the
expected value, of the
difference between the two
random variables squared, goes
to 0, this n gets big.
That's what we had with the weak
law of large numbers if
you assume that the random
variables each had a variance.
So on to something new.
On to Poisson processes.
We first have to explain what
an arrival process is.
And then we can get into
Poisson processes.
Because arrival processes are
a very broad class of
stochastic processes, in fact
discrete stochastic processes.
But they have this property of
being characterized by things
happening at various random
instance of time as opposed to
a noise waveform or something
of that sort.
So an arrival process is a
sequence of increasing random
variables, 0 less than
s1, less than s2.
What's it mean for a random
variable s1 to be less than a
random variable s2?
It means exactly the
same thing as it
means for real numbers.
s1 is less than s2 if the random
variable s2 minus s1 is
a positive random variable,
namely if it only takes on
non-negative values for all
omega in the sample space or
for all omega except for some
peculiar set of probability 0.
The differences in these arrival
epochs, why do I call
them arrival epochs?
Why do other people call
Because time is something which
gets used so often here
that it gets confusing.
So it's nice to call one thing
epochs instead of time.
And then you know what you're
talking about a little better.
The difference is s sub i minus
s sub i minus 1 for all
i greater than or equal to 2
here, with x1 equal to s1.
These are called interarrival
times and the si are called
arrival epochs.
The picture here really
shows it all.
Here we have a sequence of
arrival instance, which is
where these arrivals occur.
By definition, x1 is the time at
which is the first arrival
occurs, x2 is the difference
between the time when the
second arrival occurs and
the first arrival
occurs, and so forth.
n of t is the number of arrivals
that have occurred up
until time t.
Which is, if we draw a staircase
function for each of
these arrivals, n of t
is just the value of
that staircase function.
In other words, the counting
process, the
arrival counting process--
here's another typo in the
notes that you've got.
It calls it Poisson
counting process.
It should be arrival
What this staircase function
is is in fact
the counting process.
It says how many arrivals
there have been
up until time t.
And every once in a while,
that jumps up by 1.
So it keeps increasing by
1 at various times.
So that's the arrival
counting process.
The important thing to get out
of this is if you understand
everything about these random
variables, then you understand
everything about these
random variables.
And then you understand
everything about
these random variables.
There's a countable number of
There's an unaccountably
infinite number of these
random variables.
In other words, for every
t, n of t is a
different random variable.
I mean, it tends to be the
same for relatively large
intervals of t sometimes.
But this is a different random
variable for each value of t.
So let's proceed with that.
A sample path or sample function
of the process is a
sequence of sample values.
That's the same as we
have everywhere.
You look at a sample point
of the process.
Sample point of the whole
probability space maps into
this sequence of random
variables, s1,
s2, s3, and so forth.
If you know what the sample
value is of each one of these
random variables, then in fact,
you can draw this step
function here.
If you know the value, the
sample value, of each one of
these, in the same way,
you can again
draw this step function.
And if you know what the
subfunction is, the step
function in fact is the sample
value of n of t.
Now, there's one thing a
little peculiar here.
Each sample path corresponds
to a
particular staircase function.
And the process can be viewed
as the ensemble with joint
probability distributions of
such staircase functions.
Now, what does all that
gobbledygook mean?
Very, very often in probability
theory, we draw pictures.
And these pictures are pictures
of what happens to
random variables.
And there's a cheat
in all of that.
And the cheat here is that in
fact, this step function here
is just a generic
step function.
These points at which changes
occur are generic values at
which changes occur.
And we're representing those
values as random variables.
When you represent these as
random variables, this whole
function here, namely n
of t itself, becomes--
if you have a particular set
of values for each one of
these, then you have a
particular staircase function.
With that particular staircase
function, you have a
particular sample
path for n of t.
In other words, a sample path
for any set of these random
variables-- the arrival epochs,
or the interarrival
intervals, or n of
t for each t--
all of these are equivalent
to each other.
For this reason, when we talk
about arrival processes, it's
a little different than
what we usually do.
Because usually, we say a random
process is a sequence
or an uncountable number
of random variables.
Here, just because we can
describe it in three different
ways, this same stochastic
process gets described either
as a sequence of interarrival
intervals, or as a sequence of
arrival epochs, or as a
countable number these n of t
random variables.
And from now on, we make no
distinction between any of
these things.
We will, every once in while,
have to remind ourselves what
these pictures mean because
they look very simple.
They look like the pictures
of functions that
you're used to drawing.
But they don't really
mean the same thing.
Because this picture is drawing
a generic sample path.
For that generic sample path,
you have a set of sample
values for the Xs, a sample path
for the arrival epochs, a
sample set of values
for n of t.
And when we draw the picture
calling these random
variables, we really
mean the set of
all such step functions.
And we just automatically use
all those properties and those
relationships.
So it's not quite as simple as
what it appears to be, but
it's almost as simple.
You can also see that any sample
path can be specified
by the sample values n of t for
all t, by si for all i, or
by xi for all i.
So that essentially, an arrival
process is specified
by any one of these things.
That's exactly what
I just said.
The major relation we need to
relate the counting process to
the arrival process, well,
there's one relationship here,
which is perhaps the simplest
relationship.
But this relationship is a nice
relationship to say what
n of t is if you know
what s sub n is.
It's not quite so nice if you
know what n of t is to figure
what s sub n is.
I mean, the information is
tucked into the statement, but
it's tucked in a more convenient
way into this
statement down here.
This statement, I can see it
now after many years of
dealing with it.
I'm sure that you can
see it if you stare
at it for five minutes.
You will keep forgetting
the intuitive picture
that goes with it.
So I suggest that this is one
of the rare things in this
course that you just
ought to remember.
And then once you remember
it, you can always figure
out why it's true.
Here's the reason
why it's true.
If s sub n is equal to tau for
some tau less than or equal to
t, then n of tau has
to be equal to n.
If s sub n is equal to tau,
here's the picture here,
except there's not a tau here.
If s sub 2 is equal to
tau, then n of 2--
these are right continuous,
so n of 2 is equal to 2.
And therefore, n of tau is less
than or equal to n of t.
So that's the whole
reason down there.
You can turn this
argument around.
You can start out with n of t is
greater than or equal to n.
It means n of t is equal
to some particular n.
And turn the argument
upside down.
And you get the same argument.
So this tells you
what this is.
This tells you what this is.
If you do this for every n and
every t, then you do this for
every n and every t.
It's a very bizarre statement
because usually when you have
relationships between functions,
you don't have the
Ns and the Ts switching
around.
And in this case, the
n is the subscript.
That's the thing which says
which random variable you're
talking about.
And over here, t is the thing
which says what random
variable you're talking about.
So it's peculiar
in that sense.
It's a statement which
requires a
little bit of thought.
I apologize for dwelling
on it because once you
see it, it's obvious.
But many of these obvious
things are not obvious.
What we're going to do as we
move on is we're going to talk
about these arrival processes in
any of these three ways we
choose to talk about them.
And we're going to go back
and forth between them.
And with Poisson processes,
that's particularly easy.
We can't do a whole lot more
with arrival processes.
They're just too complicated.
I mean, arrival processes
involve almost any kind of
thing where things happen at
various points in time.
So we simplify it to something
called a renewal process.
Renewal processes are the
topic of Chapter 4.
When you get to Chapter 4, you
will perhaps say that renewal
processes are too complicated
to talk about also.
I hope after we finish Chapter
4, you won't believe that it's
too complicated to talk about.
But these are fairly complicated
processes.
But even here, it's an arrival
process where the interarrival
intervals are independent and
identically distributed.
Finally, a Poisson process is
a renewal process for which
each x sub i has an exponential
distribution.
Each interarrival has to have
the same distribution because
since it's a renewal process,
these are all IID.
And we let this distribution
function X be the generic
random variable.
And this is talking about
the distribution
function of all of them.
I don't know whether that 1
minus is in the slides I
passed out.
There's one kind of
error like that.
And I'm not sure where it is.
So anyway, lambda is some fixed
parameter called the
rate of the Poisson process.
So for each lambda greater than
0, you have a Poisson
process where each of these
interarrival intervals are
exponential random variables
of rate lambda.
So that defines a
Poisson process.
So we can all go home now
because we now know everything
about Poisson processes
in principle.
Everything we're going to say
from now on comes from this
one simple statement here that
these interarrival intervals
are exponential.
There's something very, very
special about this exponential
distribution.
And that's what makes Poisson
processes so very special.
And that special thing is this
memoryless property.
A random variable is memoryless
if it's positive.
And for all real t greater than
0 and x greater than 0,
the probability that x is
greater than t plus x is equal
to the probability that x is
greater than t times the
probability that x is
greater than x.
If you plug that in, then the
statement is the same whether
you're dealing with densities,
or PMFs, or
distribution function.
You get the same product
relationship in each case.
Since the interarrival interval
is exponential, the
probability that a random
variable x is greater than
some particular value x is equal
to e to the minus lambda
x for x greater than zero.
This you'll recognize, not as a
distribution function but as
the complementary distribution
function.
It's the probability that
X is greater than x.
So it's the complementary
distribution function
evaluated at the value of x.
This is an exponential
which is going down.
So these random variables
have a probability
density which is this.
This is f sub x of X. And they
have a distribution function
which is this.
And they have a complementary
distribution
function which is this.
Now, this is f of c.
This is f.
So there's nothing
much to them.
And now there's a theorem
which says that a random
variable is memoryless if and
only if it is exponential.
We just showed here that an
exponential random variable is
memoryless.
To show it the other way
is almost obvious.
You take this definition here.
You take the logarithm of
each of these sides.
When you get the logarithm of
this, it says the logarithm of
the probability x is greater
than p plus x is the logarithm
of this plus the logarithm
of this.
What we have to show to get an
exponential is that this
logarithm is linear
in its argument t.
Now, if you have this is equal
to the sum of this and this
for all t and x, it's sort
of says it's linear.
There's an exercise, I think
it's Exercise 2.4, which shows
that you have to be a
little bit careful.
Or at least as it points
out, very, very picky
mathematicians have to be a
little bit careful with that.
And you can worry about that
or not as you choose.
So that's the theorem.
That's why Poisson processes
are special.
And that's why we can
do all the things
we can do with them.
The reason why we call it
memoryless is more apparent if
we use conditional
probabilities.
With conditional probabilities,
the probability
that the random variable X is
greater than t plus x, given
that it's greater than t, is
equal to the probability that
X is greater than x.
If people in a checkout line
have exponential service times
and you've waited 15 minutes for
the person in front, what
is his or her remaining service
time, assuming the
service time is exponential?
What's the answer?
You've waited 15 minutes.
Your original service time is
exponential with rate lambda.
What's the remaining
service time?
Well, the answer is
it's exponential.
That's this memoryless
property.
It's called memoryless because
the random variable doesn't
remember how long it
hasn't happened.
So you can think of an
exponential random variable as
something which takes
place in time.
And in each instant of time, it
might or might not happen.
And if it hasn't happened yet,
there's still the same
probability in every remaining
increment that it's going to
happen then.
So you haven't gained anything
and you haven't lost anything
by having to wait this long.
Here's an interesting question
which you can tie yourself in
knots for a little bit.
Has your time waiting
been wasted?
Namely the time you still have
to wait is exponential with
the same rate as
it was before.
So the expected amount of time
you have to wait is still the
same as when you got into line
15 minutes ago with this one
very slow person in
front of you.
So have you wasting your time?
Well, you haven't
gained anything.
But you haven't really wasted
your time either.
Because if you have to get
served in that line, then at
some point, you're going to
have to go in that line.
And you might look for a time
when the line is very short.
You might be lucky and find
a time when the line is
completely empty.
And then you start getting
served right away.
But if you ignore those issues,
then in fact, in a
sense, you have wasted
your time.
Another more interesting
question then is why do you
move to another line if somebody
takes a long time?
All of you have had
this experience.
You're in a supermarket.
Or you're at an airplane counter
or any of the places
where you have to wait
for service.
There's somebody, one person in
front of you, who has been
there forever.
And it seems as if they're going
to stay there forever.
You notice another line
that only has one
person being served.
And most of us, especially very
impatient people like me,
I'm going to walk over and
get into that other line.
And the question is, is that
rational or isn't it rational?
If the service times are
exponential, it is not rational.
It doesn't make any difference
whether I stay where I am or
go to the other line.
If the service times are fixed
duration, namely suppose every
service time takes 10 minutes
and I've waited for a long
time, is it rational for me
to move to the other line?
Absolutely not because I'm
almost at the end of that 10
minutes now.
And I'm about to be served.
So why do we move?
Is it just psychology, that
we're very impatient?
I don't think so.
I think it's because we have all
seen that an awful lot of
lines, particularly airline
reservation lines, and if your
plane doesn't fly or something,
and you're trying
to get rescheduled, or any of
these things, the service time
is worse than Poisson in the
sense that if you've waited
for 10 minutes, your expected
remaining waiting time is
greater than it was before
you started waiting.
The longer you wait, the longer
your expected remaining
waiting time is.
And that's called a heavy-tailed
distribution.
What most of us have noticed, I
think, in our lives is that
an awful lot of waiting lines
that human beings wait in are
in fact heavy-tailed.
So that in fact is part of the
reason why we move if somebody
takes a long time.
It's interesting to see
how the brain works.
Because I'm sure that none
of you have ever really
rationally analyzed this
question of why you move.
Have you?
I mean, I have because
I teach probability
courses all the time.
But I don't think anyone who
doesn't teach probability
courses would be crazy enough
to waste their time on a
question like this.
But your brain automatically
figures that out.
I mean, your brain is smart
enough to know that if you've
waited for a long time, you're
probably going to have to wait
for an even longer time.
And it makes sense to move to
another line where your
waiting time is probably
going to be shorter.
So you're pretty smart if you
don't think about it too much.
Here's an interesting theorem
now that makes use of this
memoryless property.
This is Theorem 2.2.1
in the text.
It's not stated terribly
well there.
And I'll tell you why
in a little bit.
It's not stated too badly.
I mean, it's stated correctly.
But it's just a little hard to
understand what it says.
If you have a Poisson process
of rate lambda and you're
looking at any given time
t, here's t down here.
You're looking at the
process of time t.
The interval z--
here's the interval z here--
from t until the next arrival
has distribution e to the
minus lambda z.
And it has this distribution
for all real numbers
greater than 0.
The random variable Z is
independent of n of t.
In other words, this random
variable here is independent
of how many arrivals there
have been at time t.
And given this, it's independent
of s sub n, which
is the time at which the
last arrival occurred.
Namely, here's n
of t equals 2.
Here's s of 2 at time tau.
So given both n of t and s sub
2 in this case, or s sub n of
t as we might call it, and
that's what gets confusing.
And I'll talk about
that later.
Given those two things, the
number n of arrivals in 0t--
well, I got off.
The random variable Z is
independent of n of t.
And given n of t, Z is
independent of all of these
arrival epochs up
until time t.
And it's also independent of
n of t for all values of
tau up until t.
That's what the theorem
states.
What the theorem states is that
this memoryless property
that we've just stated for
random variables is really a
property of the Poisson
process.
When we say that if a random
variable, it's a little hard
to see why would anyone was
calling it memoryless.
When you state it for a Poisson
process, it's very
obvious why we want to
call it memoryless.
It says that this time here from
t, from any arbitrary t,
until the next arrival occurs,
that this is independent of
all this junk that happens
before or up to time t.
That's what the theorem says.
Here's a sort of a
half proof of it.
There's a careful proof
in the notes.
The statement in the notes
is not that careful,
but the proof is.
And the proof is drawn
out perhaps too much.
You can find your comfort level
between this and the
much longer version
in the notes.
You might understand
it well from this.
Given n of t is equal to 2 in
this case, and in general,
given that n of t is equal to
any constant n, and given that
s sub 2 where this 2 is equal to
that 2, given that s sub 2
is equal to tau, then x3, this
value here, the interarrival
arrival time from this previous
arrival before t to
the next arrival after t, namely
x3, is the thing which
bridges across this time that
we selected, t. t is not a
random thing.
t is just something you're
interested in.
I want to catch a plane at 7
o'clock tomorrow evening.
t then is 7 o'clock
tomorrow evening.
What's the time from the last
plane that went out to New
York until the next plane that's
going out to New York?
If the planes are so screwed
up that the schedule means
nothing, then they're just
flying out whenever
they can fly out.
That's the meaning
of this x3 here.
That says that x3, in fact,
has to be bigger
than t minus tau.
If we're given that n of t is
equal to 2 and that the time
of the previous arrival is at
tau, we're given that there
haven't been any arrivals
between the last arrival
before t and t.
That's what we're given.
This was the last arrival before
t by the assumption
we've made.
So we're assuming there's
nothing in this interval.
And then we're asking what is
the remaining time until x3 is
all finished.
And that's the random variable
that we call Z. So Z is x3
minus t minus tau.
The complementary distribution
function of Z conditional on
both n and on s, this n here
and this s here is then
exponential with e to
the minus lambda Z.
Now, if I know that this is
exponential, what can I say
about the random variable
Z itself?
Well, there's an easy way to
find the distribution of Z
when you know Z conditional
onto other things.
You take what the distribution
is conditional on, each value
of n and s.
You then multiply that by the
probability that n and s have
those particular values.
And then you integrate.
Now, we can look at this and
say we don't have to go
through all of that.
And in fact, we won't know what
the distribution of n is.
And we certainly won't know what
the distribution of this
previous arrival is for
quite a long time.
Why don't we need
to know that?
Well, because we know that
whatever n of t is and
whatever s sub n of t is doesn't
make any difference.
The distribution of Z is
still the same thing.
So we know this has to be the
unconditional distribution
function of Z also even without
knowing anything about
n or knowing about s.
And that means that the
complementary distribution
function of Z is equal to e to
the minus lambda Z also.
So that's sort of a proof if you
want to be really picky.
And I would suggest you
try to be picky.
When you read the notes, try to
understand why one has to
say a little more than
one says here.
Because that's the
way you really
understand these things.
But this really gives you
the idea of the proof.
And it's pretty close
to a complete proof.
This is saying what
we just said.
The conditional distribution
of Z doesn't vary with the
conditioning values.
n of t equals n.
And s sub n equals tau.
So Z is statistically
independent of n of t and s
sub n of t.
You should look at the text
again, as I said, for more
careful proof of that.
What is this random variable
s sub n of t?
It's clear from the picture
what it is.
s sub n of t is the last
arrival before
we're at time t.
That's what it is in
the picture here.
How do you define a random
variable like that?
There's a temptation to
do it the following
way which is incorrect.
There's a temptation to say,
well, conditional on n of t,
suppose n of t is equal to n.
Let me then find the
distribution of s sub n.
And that's not the right
way to do it.
Because s sub n of t and n
of t are certainly not
independent.
n of t tells you what random
variable you want to look at.
How do you define a random
variable in terms of a mapping
from the sample space omega onto
the set of real numbers?
So what you do here is you look
at a sample point omega.
It maps into this random
variable n of t, the sample
value of that at omega,
that's sum value n.
And then you map that same
sample point into--
now, you know which random
variable it is
you're looking at.
You take that same omega and
map it into sub time tau.
So that's what we mean
by s sub n of t.
If your mind glazes over at
that, don't worry about it.
Think about it a
little bit now.
Come back and think
about it later.
Every time I don't think about
this for two weeks, my mind
glazes over when I look at it.
And I have to think very hard
about what this very peculiar
looking random variable is.
When I have a random variable
where I have a sequence of
random variables, and I have a
random variable which is a
random selection among those
random variables, it's a very
complicated animal.
And that's what this is.
But we've just said
what it is.
So you can think about
it as you go.
The theorem essentially
extends the idea of
memorylessness to the entire
Poisson process.
In other words, this says that
a Poisson process is
memoryless.
You look at a particular
time t.
And the time until the next
arrival is independent of
everything that's going
before that.
Starting at any time tau,
yeah, well, subsequent
interrarrival times are
independent of Z
and also of the past.
I'm waving my hands
a little bit here.
But in fact, what I'm
saying is right.
We have these interarrival
intervals that we know are
independent.
The interarrival intervals which
have occurred completely
before time t are independent of
this random variable Z. The
next interarrival interval after
Z is independent of all
the interarrival intervals
before that.
And those interarrival intervals
before that are
determined by the counting
process up until time t.
So the counting process
corresponds to this
corresponding interarrival
process.
It's n of t prime minus n of t
for t prime greater than t.
In other words, we now want to
look at a counting process
which starts at time t and
follows whatever it has to
follow from this original
counting process.
And what we're saying is this
first arrival and this process
starting at time t is
independent of everything that
went before.
And every subsequent
interarrival time after that
is independent of everything
before time t.
So this says that the process n
of t prime minus n of t as a
process nt prime.
This is a counting process nt
prime defined for t prime
greater than t.
So for fixed t, we now have
something which we can view
over variable t prime as
a counting process.
It's a Poisson process shifted
to start at time t, ie, for
each t prime, n of t prime minus
the n of t has the same
distribution as n of
t prime minus t.
Same for joint distributions.
In other words, this
random variable Z
is exponential again.
And all the future interarrival
times are
exponential.
So it's defined in exactly the
same way as the original
random process is.
So it's statistically
the same process.
Which says two things
about it.
Everything is the same.
And everything is independent.
We will call that stationary.
Everything is the same.
And independent, everything
is independent.
And then we'll try to sort out
how things can be the same but
also be independent.
Oh, we already know that.
We have two IID random
variables, x1 and x2.
They're IID.
They're independent and
identically distributed.
Identity distributed means
that in one sense,
they are the same.
But they're also independent
of each other.
So the random variables are
defined in the same way.
And in that sense, they're
stationary.
But they're independent of each
other by the definition
of independence.
So our new process is
independent of the old process
in the interval 0 up to t.
When we're talking about Poisson
processes and also
arrival processes, we always
talk about intervals which are
open on the left and closed
on the right.
That's completely arbitrary.
But if you don't make one
convention or the other, you
could make them closed on the
left and open on the right,
and that would be
consistent also.
But nobody does.
And it would be much
more confusing.
So it's much easier to make
things closed on the right.
So we're up to stationary and
independent increments.
Well, we're not up to there.
We're almost finished
with that.
We've virtually already said
that increments are stationary
and independent.
And an increment is just a piece
of a Poisson process.
That's an increment,
a piece of it.
So a counting process has the
stationary increment property
if n of t prime minus n of t has
the same distribution as n
of t prime minus t for all
t prime greater than t
greater than 0.
In other words, you look at
this counting process.
Goes up.
Then you start at some
particular value of t.
Let me draw a picture of that.
Make it a little clearer.
And the new Poisson process
starts at this value and goes
up from there.
So this thing here is
what we call n of t
prime minus n of t.
Because here's n of t.
Here's t prime out here for
any value out here.
And we're looking at the number
of arrivals up until
time t prime.
And what we're talking about,
when we're talking about n of
t prime minus n of t, we're
talking about what happens in
this region here.
And we're saying that this is
a Poisson process again.
And now in a minute, we're going
to say that this Poisson
process is independent of what
happened up until time t.
But Poisson processes have this
stationary increment property.
And a counting process has the
independent increment property
if for every sequence of times,
t1, t2, up to t sub n.
The random variables n of t1 and
tilde of t1, t2, we didn't
talk about that.
But I think it's defined
on one of those slides.
n of t and t prime is defined as
n of t prime minus n of t.
So n of t and t prime is really
the number of arrivals
that have occurred from
t up until t prime--
open on t, closed on t prime.
So a counting process has the
independent increment property
if for every finite set of
times, these random variables
here are independent.
The number of arrivals in the
first increment, number of
arrivals in the second
increment, number of arrivals
in the third increment, no
matter how you choose t1, t2,
up to t sub n, what happens here
is independent of what
happens here, is independent
of what happens
here, and so forth.
It's not only that
what happens in
Las Vegas stays there.
It's that what happens in
Boston stays there, what
happens in Philadelphia stays
there, and so forth.
What happens anywhere
stays anywhere.
It never gets out of there.
That's what we mean by
independence in this case.
So it's a strong statement.
But we've essentially said that
Poisson processes have
that property.
So this property implies is the
number of arrivals in each
of the set of non-overlapping
intervals are independent
random variables.
For a Poisson process, we've
seen that the number of
arrivals in t sub i minus 1 to t
sub i is independent of this
whole set of random
variables here.
Now, remember that when we're
talking about multiple random
variables, we say that multiple
random variables are
independent.
It's not enough to be pairwise
They all have to
be independent.
But this thing we've just said
says that this is independent
of all of these things.
If this is independent of all of
these things, and then the
next interval n of ti, ti plus
1, is independent of
everything in the past, and so
forth all the way up, then all
of those random variables are
statistically independent of
each other.
So in fact, we're saying more
than pairwise statistical
independence.
If you're panicking about
these minor differences
between pairwise independence
and real independence, don't
worry about it too much.
Because the situations
where that happens
are relatively rare.
They don't happen
all the time.
But they do happen
occasionally.
So you should be aware of it.
You shouldn't get in
a panic about it.
Because normally, you don't
have to worry about it.
In other words, when you're
taking a quiz, don't worry
about any of the fine points.
Figure out roughly how
to do the problems.
Do them more or less.
And then come back and deal with
the fine points later.
Don't spend the whole quiz time
wrapped up on one little
fine point and not get
to anything else.
One of the important things to
learn in understanding a
subject like this is to figure
out what are the fine points,
what are the important points.
How do you tell whether
something is important in a
particular context.
And that just takes intuition.
That takes some intuition from
working with these processes.
And you pick that
up as you go.
But anyway, we wind up now
with the statement that
Poisson processes have
stationary and independent
increments.
Which means that what happens
in each interval is
independent of what happens
in each other interval.
So we're done with that until
we get to alternate
definitions of a Poisson
process.
And we now want to deal with
the Erlang and the Poisson
distributions, which are just
very plug and chug kinds of
things to a certain extent.
For a Poisson process of rate
lambda, the density function
of arrival epoch s2, s2 is
the sum of x1 plus x2.
x1 is an exponential random
variable of rate lambda.
x2 is an independent random
How do you find the probability
density function
as a sum of two independent
random variables, which both
have a density?
You convolve them.
That's something that you've
known ever since you studied
any kind of linear systems, or
from any probability, or
anything else.
Convolution is the way to
solve this problem.
When you convolve these
two random variables,
here I've done it.
You get lambda squared t times
e to the minus lambda t.
This kind of form here with an
e to the minus lambda t, and
with a t, or t squared, or so
forth, is a particularly easy
form to integrate.
So we just do this
again and again.
And when we do it again and
again, we find out that the
density function as a sum of n
of these random variables, you
keep picking up an extra lambda
every time you convolve
in another exponential
random variable.
You pick up an extra factor of
t whenever you do this again.
This stays the same
as it does here.
And strangely enough, this n
minus 1 factorial appears down
here when you start integrating
something with
some power of t in it.
So when you integrate this,
this is what you get.
And it's called the
Erlang density.
Any questions about this?
Or any questions
about anything?
I'm getting hoarse.
I need questions.
[LAUGHS]
There's nothing much to
worry about there.
But now, we want to stop and
smell the roses while doing
all this computation.
Let's do this a slightly
different way.
The joint density of x1 up to
x sub n is lambda x1 times e
to the minus lambda x1, times
lambda x2, times e to the
minus lambda x2, and so forth.
So excuse me.
The probability density of an
exponential random variable is
lambda times e to the
minus lambda x.
So the joint density is lambda
e to the minus lambda x1.
I told you I was
getting hoarse.
And my mind is getting hoarse.
So you better start asking
some questions or I will
evolve into meaningless
chatter.
And this is just lambda to the
n times e to the minus lambda
times the summation of x sub
i from i equals 1 to n.
Now, that's sort of interesting
because this joint
density is just this
simple-minded thing.
You can write it as lambda to
the n times e to the minus
lambda s sub n, where
s sub n is the
time of the n-th arrival.
This says that the joint
distribution of all of these
interarrival times only
depends on when the
last one comes in.
And you can transform that to a
joint density on each of the
arrival epochs as lambda to
the n times e to the minus
lambda s sub n.
Is this obvious to everyone?
You're lying.
If you're not shaking your
head, you're lying.
Because it's not
obvious at all.
What we're doing here, it's sort
of obvious if you look at
the picture.
It's not obvious when you
do the mathematics.
What the picture says
is-- let me see if I
find the picture again.
OK.
Here's the picture up here.
We're looking at these
interarrival intervals.
I think it'll be clearer if
I draw it a different way.
There we go.
Let's just draw this
in a line.
Here's 0.
Here's s1.
Here's s2.
Here's s3.
And here's s4.
And here's x1.
Here's x2.
Here's x3.
And here's x4.
Now, what we're talking about,
we can go from the density of
each of these intervals to the
density of each of these sums
in a fairly straightforward
way.
If you write this all out as a
density, what you find is that
in making a transformation
from the density of these
interarrival intervals to the
density of these, what you're
essentially doing is taking this
density and multiplying
it by a matrix.
And the matrix is a diagonal
matrix, is an
upper triangular matrix.
Because this depends
only on this.
This depends only on
this and this.
each of these.
So it's a triangular matrix with
terms on the diagonal.
And when you look at a matrix
like that, the terms on the
diagonal are 1s because what's
getting added each time is 1
times a new variable.
So we have a matrix with 1s on
the main diagonal and other
stuff above that.
And what that means is that
when you make this
transformation in densities,
the determinant of
that matrix is 1.
And the value that you then
get when you go from the
density of these to the density
of these, it's a
uniform density again.
So in fact, it has to
look like what we
said it looks like.
So I was kidding you there.
It's not so obvious how to
do that although it looks
reasonable.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
Is it also valid to make an
argument based on symmetry?
PROFESSOR: It will be later.
The symmetry is not
clear here yet.
I mean, the symmetry isn't
clear because you're
starting at time 0.
And because you're starting
at time 0, you don't have
symmetry here yet.
If we started at time 0 and we
ended at some time t, we could
try to claim there is some
kind of symmetry between
everything that happened
in the middle.
And we'll try to
do that later.
But at the moment, we would get
into even more trouble if
we try to do it by symmetry.
But anyway, what this is saying
is that this joint
density is really--
if you know where this point is,
the joint density of all
of these things remains the same
no matter how you move
these things around.
If I move s1 around a little
bit, it means that x1 gets a
little smaller, x2 gets
a little bit bigger.
And if you look at the joint
density there, the joint
density stays absolutely the
same because you have e to the
minus lambda x1 times e to
the minus lambda x2.
And the sum of the two for a
fixed value here is the same
as it was before.
So you can move all of these
things around in any
way you want to.
And the joint density depends
only on the last one.
And that's a very strange
property and it's a very
interesting property.
And it sort of is the same as
this independent increment
property that we've been
talking about.
But we'll see why that
is in just a minute.
But anyway, once we have that
property, we can then
integrate this over the volume
of s1, s2, s3, and s4, over
that volume which has the
property that it stops at that
one particular point there.
And we do that integration
subject to the fact that s3
has to be less than or equal to
s4, s2 has to be less than
or equal to s3, and
so forth down.
When you do that integration,
you get exactly the same thing
as you got before when you
did the integration.
The integration that you did
before was essentially doing
this, if you look at what
you did before.
You were taking lambda times e
to the minus lambda x times
lambda times t minus x.
And the x doesn't make
any difference here.
The x cancels out.
That's exactly what's
going on.
And if you do it in terms of s1
and s2, the s1 cancels out.
The s1 is the same as x here.
So there is that cancellation
here.
And therefore, this Erlang
density is just a marginal
distribution of a very
interesting joint
distribution, which depends
only on the last term.
So next, we have a theorem
which says for a Poisson
process, the PMF for n of t, the
Probability Mass Function,
is the Poisson PMF.
It sounds like I'm not really
saying anything because what
else would it be?
Because you've always heard that
the Poisson PMF is this
particular function here.
Well, in fact, there's
some reason for that.
And in fact, if we want to say
that a Poisson process is
defined in terms of these
exponential interarrival
times, then we have to
show that this is
consistent with that.
The way I'll prove that
here, this is a
little more than a PF.
Maybe we should say it's a
P-R-O-F. Leave out the double
O because it's not
quite complete.
But what we want to do is to
calculate the probability that
the n plus first arrival occurs
sometime between t and
t plus delta.
And we'll do it in two
different ways.
And one way involves the
probability mass function for
the Poisson.
The other way involves
the Erlang density.
And since we already know the
Erlang density, we can use
that to get the PMF
for n of t.
So using the Erlang density,
the probability that the n
plus first arrival falls in
this little tiny interval
here, we're thinking of
delta as being small.
And we're going to let
delta approach 0.
It's going to be the density
of the n plus first arrival
times delta plus o of delta.
o of delta is something that
goes to 0 as delta increases
faster than delta does.
It's something which has the
property that o of delta
divided by delta goes to
0 as delta gets large.
So this is just saying that this
is approximately equal to
the density of the n plus
first arrival times this
[INAUDIBLE]
here.
The density stays essentially
constant over
a very small delta.
It's a continuous density.
Next, we use the independent
increment property, which says
that the probability that t is
less than sn plus 1, is less
than or equal to t plus delta,
is the PMF that n of t is
equal to n at the beginning is
the interval, and then that in
the middle of the interval,
there's exactly one arrival.
And the probabilities of exactly
one arrival, is just
lambda delta plus o of delta.
Namely, that's because of the
independent increment property.
What's this o of delta
doing out here?
Why isn't this exactly
equal to this?
And why do I need
something else?
What am I leaving out
of this equation?
The probability that
our arrival comes--
here's t.
Here's t plus delta.
I'm talking about something
happening here.
At this point, n of t is here.
And I'm finding the probability
that n of t plus
delta is equal to n of
t plus 1 essentially.
I'm looking for the probability
of there being one
arrival in this interval here.
So what's the matter
with that equation?
This is the probability that
the n plus first arrival
occurs somewhere in this
interval here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that last term
then the probability that
there's not anymore other
parameter standards as well?
PROFESSOR: It doesn't
include-- yes.
This last term which I had to
add is in fact the negligible
term that at time n of t, there
is less than n arrivals.
And then I get 2 arrivals in
this little interval delta.
So that's why I need
that extra term.
But anyway, when I relate these
two terms, I get the
probability mass function of n
of t is equal to the Erlang
density at t, where
the n plus first
arrival divided by lambda.
And that's what that
term is there.
So that gives us the
Poisson PMF.
Interesting observation about
this, it's a function
only of lambda t.
It's not a function of lambda
or t separately.
It's a function only of the
two of them together.
It has to be that.
Because you can use scaling
arguments on this.
If you have a Poisson process
of rate lambda and I measure
things in millimeters instead
of centimeters,
what's going to happen?
My rate is going to change
by a factor of 10.
My values of t are going to
change by a factor of 10.
This is a probability
mass function.
That has to stay the same.
So this has to be a function
only of the product lambda t
because of scaling
argument here.
Now, the other thing here, and
this is interesting because if
you look at n of t, the number
of arrivals up until time t is
the sum of the number of
arrivals up until some shorter
time t1 plus the number of
arrivals between t1 and t.
We know that the number
of arrivals up
until time t1 is Poisson.
The number of arrivals between
t1 and t is Poisson.
Those two values are independent
of each other.
I can choose t1 in the middle
to be anything I
want to make it.
And this says that the sum of
two Poisson random variables
has to be Poisson.
Now, I'm very lazy.
And I've gone through life
without ever convolving this
PMF to find out that in fact
the sum of 2 Poisson random
variables is in fact
Poisson itself.
Because I actually believe the
argument I just went through.
If you're skeptical, you will
probably want to actually do
the digital convolution to
show that the sum of two
independent Poisson random
variables is in fact Poisson.
And it extends to any [? tay ?]
disjoint interval.
So the same argument says that
any sum of Poisson random
variables is Poisson.
I do want to get through any
alternate definitions of a
Poisson process because
that makes a natural
stopping point here.
Question-- is it true that any
arrival process for which n of
t has a Poisson probability
mass function for a given
lambda and for all
t is a Poisson
process of rate lambda?
In other words, that's a
pretty strong property.
It says I found the probability
mass functions for
n of t at every value of t.
Does that describe a process?
Well, you see the
answer there.
As usual, marginal PMFs,
distribution functions don't
specify a process because they
don't specify the joint
probabilities.
But here, we've just pointed
out that these joint
probabilities are
all independent.
You can take a set of
probability mass functions for
this interval, this interval,
and so forth.
And for any set of t1, t2, and
so forth up, we know that the
number of arrivals in zero to
t1, the number of arrivals in
t1 to t2, and so forth all the
way up are all independent
random variables.
And therefore, when we know the
Poisson probability mass
function, we really also know,
and we've also shown, that
these random variables are
independent of each other.
We have the joint PMF for any
sum of these random variables.
So in fact, in this particular
case, it's enough to know what
the probability mass function
is at each time t plus the
fact that we have this
independent increment property.
And we need the stationary
increment property, too, to
know that these values are
the same at each t.
So the theorem is that if an
arrival process has the
stationary and independent
increment properties, and if n
of t has the Poisson PMF for
given lambda and all t greater
than 0, then the process itself
has to be Poisson.
VHW stands for Violently
Hand Waving.
So that's even a little
worse than a PF.
Says the stationary and
independent increment
properties show that the joint
distribution of arrivals over
any given set of disjoint
intervals is that
of a Poisson process.
And clearly that's enough.
And it almost is.
And you should read the proof in
the notes which does just a
little more than that to make
this an actual proof.
OK.
I think I'll stop there.
And we will talk a little
bit about the Bernoulli
process next time.
Thank you.